du coup ses soudards
et c'était les mêmes odeurs
j'ai laissé couler m
mais pleure vous êtes au québec pour
nous présenter votre spectacle hommage à
marc barrât d'où vous est venue cette
idée de rendre hommage à cette grande
hauteur que possible c'est parce que je
suis connue barbe arabe
depuis ça fait à peu près ce fait 20 ans
qui a des partis que les parties qu'elle
est toujours présente en moi mais j'ai
conservé 50 or donc que je fonctionne
barak
je suis avec elle suivant il ya des tas
de choses que j'écoute jamais ses
chansons qui est absent trop forte
nous avons la moindre au second single
mais je l'entends sourire je vois des
tas de choses qui toi que jamais quand
on pense à quelqu'un on ne sait pas
pourquoi mais vous passez d'un seul coup
hop vous avez une pensée de quelqu'un
qui vous est cher ou qui a disparu et
vous dites voilà c'est ainsi ça veut
dire que les morts nous parle moi j'ai
des tas de choses comme ça où je vois
guillot je vois de dd où je vois
françois truffaut web russe via la
barbara et c'est vrai qu'il ya des
cépages les vois comme quelqu'un c'est
qu'ils deviennent hamoir pourquoi tout à
coup je pense à elle ou à eux à certains
mois alors que j'ai ma tête était
totalement de libre ma mémoire me diffus
des images confuse
et je mens et vous irez gelé reconstruit
vous avez beaucoup parlé de barbara qui
est parti trop vite comme johnny
hallyday comme un certaine époque
françois truffaut est ce que ces
disparitions vous font réfléchir à votre
propre des noms du mois tant mieux ce
serait bien de toute façon s'il est très
bien quand on part tous les soirs quand
on s'endort
si on se réveille pas perdre si elle ne
suis pas réveillé non c'est très bien je
pense que les plus belles des morceaux
quand on part dans un sommeil alors
c'est plus dur pour ceux qui rêvent mais
il faut préparer les choses je vais te
souvenir et je m'attaque au brun de ma
mémoire
le pire c'est l'agonie la maladie oui ça
c'est difficile il faudrait pas de
l'accord légumes là je pense que la
piqûre s'impose
je n'aime pas la mort mais ça ne me fait
pas peur c'est très bien c'est une c'est
un repos éternel d' puisque personne ne
connaît jamais même dans le
des religions catholique je ne crois pas
à la résurrection
je crois des résolutions métaphorique
oui mais
gsm les uc et revenir 1 avant que le
soir ne se pose
j'ai voulu voir
ma maison fleurie sous des roses g
vous avez traversé l'atlantique pour
présenter cet hommage à barbara
important pour vous je demande raconter
l'histoire la barbarie au québec au
québec - non je sais pas d'abord j'aime
le québec
j'aime pas l'amérique mais j'aime le
québec et puis c'est vrai que j'aime
l'histoire surtout bon soir montréal
dansoir belle province comme des espaces
ici beaucoup les espaces puis l'esprit
les gens c'est pousser c'est pas très
peuplés comparé à l'espace qui est
énorme j'arrive du japon la housse et
des trois quarts de la france plus du
plus du double de populations non c'est
surtout le voyage qui est intéressant je
ne vous ai jamais détesté mais je ne
comprenais pas pourquoi vous étiez
devenu si distante après avoir embrassé
gérard depardieu c'est 200 films
nous avons tous un souvenir qui est
rattachée à vous qu'est-ce que vous
n'avez pas encore fait mais que vous
aimeriez faire de rien parce que c'est
très bien en ce moment dans un espèce de
vide total et ses souvenirs qui lui
permet de faire entrer l'amour des gens
je suis traitement
je dirais amoureux des gens même des
cons peut-être quand ils entreront je
veux je regarde à côté mais je suis
vraiment fasciné par là les sociétés et
les cultures et il ya vraiment bien
vraiment de quoi s'intéresser csss
oublier aussi de voir que les cultures
et les sont fascinantes et la
géopolitique est fascinante
la politique m'emmerde considérablement
mais là l'homme la femme les rapports
sont fascinants vous venez de dire que
la politique vous emmerde mais vous ne
voulez pas en parler pourquoi pourquoi
tu dois les politiques ray le acide mais
qui parle politique du bts et parfois à
bas nylon c'est plus fort que le
roquefort
non c'est pas intéressant puisqu'il se
connaît pas d'homme qui puisse nous
faire ce qu'ils disent à savoir vouloir
notre bien je ne pense pas en avait un à
le christ est encore de crise son
discours était plutôt révolutionnaire
qu'autre chose mais je ne crois pas
jardin
[Musique]
bailly
je sors de là
vive le québec libre dirait l'autre